[Music]
I want to
stay with me
that voice Sam Smith burst onto the
scene with her 2014 debut album in the
Lonely Hour and since then Sam has
become one of music's biggest stars
the following year Sam won four Grammys
including Best New Artist and best pop
vocal album I feel like Kate Winslet the
Oscars right now
well Sam had their own Oscar moment in
2016. winning best original song for
writings on the wall from the film
specter
I just get inspired by real feelings so
that's what I'm trying to do and Sam
didn't stop there after releasing their
second album The Thrill of It All
followed by Love Goes they had become
one of music's top artists reaching
album sales of 30 million worldwide
[Music]
and Beyond music we also love their
honesty and how they use social media to
promote self-love and self-acceptance
like Sam letting the world know their
pronouns in a heartfelt post and sharing
their Newfound body positivity a few
years ago now and there was just one
summer that I just got so fed up with
and not being able to take my top off
around the pool for about four months I
really tackled hard against that and it
just really Set Me Free and it set me
free in every sense
baby I am learning how to love me more
recently Sam scored their first number
one on the Billboard Hot 100 alongside
Kim Petrus for their song Unholy making
history as the first openly non-binary
and transgender artists to top the chart